[Music]
160,000 miles that's on average how
often you'll use your car insurance but
what if you could get help with more
more often maybe save a couple of bucks
on clothes or restaurants what if you
could even get rescued roadside when a
tire goes flat or your battery dies you
can when you remember and your auto
insurance is Triple A insurance that's
not just insurance talk to a triple-a
insurance agent or visit triplea.com
slash insurance to learn more about how
Triple A works at every mile radio
[Music]
welcome this is perfectly healthy and
tone radio with your Oh Darrin Batman
McDuck and now prepare to get fat what's
crackin welcome back to another episode
of perfectly healthy and tone radio I'm
your host Darrin fat man
McDuffie and today gonna have a good
episode actually just a little bit
earlier than what I'm used to I'm always
up but a little bit earlier show than
what I'm used to but I wanted to
accommodate our guests and I know he has
a busy schedule but before I get to him
and reading his bio and getting him on
just wanted to wish all the mothers out
there happy Mother's Day I know that was
yesterday I live here in South Florida
and the beaches were absolutely packed
everybody was out on the beach I spent
an hour looking for a parking spot and
finally got a chance to relax on the
beach I know that this time now is
upcoming that things are going to start
getting more and more packed on the
beach here in South Florida we're coming
up on Memorial Day which is I think the
last week of May and we're in May now so
I know that things are going to be more
and more tact and a lot of people are
going to be visiting South Florida which
is always the case but what can you say
I live in Paradise not complaining love
living here love being able to drive 15
minutes 10 15 or
ten minutes to the beach and being able
to enjoy that nothing like being able to
get off work or get done with what
you're doing and then take some time and
just go to the beach and relax so um
this show is one of the shows I've been
really looking forward to doing we have
some scheduling conflicts a couple of
times think we were supposed to do this
show back in February I believe and
something happened and we weren't able
to schedule the show but I was looking
through different things as I always do
to research for the show and came akan
up came across this gentleman's a book
he has actually has two books and today
we'll be discussing one of them but I
was like man I'm hoping that I can get
this guy on and sent an email and
finally the email was responded to and
now I'm able to have them on but before
I get them on let me read his bio born
and raised in Missouri dr. Joel Wallach
attended the University of Missouri
where he received a bachelor's degree in
science of Agriculture a veterinarian
for 30 years he worked as a research
veterinarian pathologist with the
National Institute of Health for the
Center for the biology of natural
systems Washington University st. Louis
Missouri hope I'm pronouncing this right
York's regional primary Research Center
in Atlanta Georgia at Emory University
having discovered and identified the
first animal models for cystic fibrosis
we'll be talking about that he found
that he could reproduce their condition
at will because it was a nutritional
deficiency his fine offered great
promise for children with the disease
but when he made it public the Institute
fired him on 24 hours notice and we'll
again we'll be talking more about that
because I'm very interested in that
jargon and perplex dr. Wallach made the
decision to go to medical school so we
could treat the children for cystic
fibrosis himself
dr. Wallace innovative slam is derived
from his background in veterinarian
medicine because there's no health
insurance animal products such as meat
and dairy are kept affordable by
preventing and curing diseases with
nutritional formulas in animal feed when
he started incorporating similar
nutritional formulas with people where
it got out got out that if you're not
happy with your doctor go see dr.
Wallach he'll treat you like a dog well
you'll get better love that love that
dr. Wallach welcome to perfectly healthy
and tone radio how are you okay thank
you so very much appreciate your
hospitality so early in the morning
you're in a Salt Lake City so it's about
eight o'clock for you so you're probably
just getting your voice going I've been
out walking around the lake and getting
in tune with nature so I've got a little
bit more of a head start on you and I
got my coffee here ready for the
interview okay we're ready
y'all are you ready okay all right well
you have one of the most interesting
backgrounds of anyone that I've ever
interviewed you are you were a
veterinarian and then you kind of got
into the health field of helping people
but talk a little bit about your
background in a veterinarian and how
that prepared you for getting into
dealing or helping people sure well make
long story short I as a kid in junior
high and high school in first couple
years university I worked with Marlin
Perkins the old mutual mahalo Wild
Kingdom show at the st. Louis Zoo and I
did a lot of things for him since I was
a farm kid I would do things the city
kids wouldn't do and again to make a
long story short
halfway through venery school I had
already graduated agricultural school so
as a graduate student I liked pathology
so I started taking pathology courses
towards a PhD in pathology and as a
graduate student I ran into the first
mass die-off in America from pollution
it was documental wrote it up got it
published and peer-review refereed
scientific journals I'm sure it happened
many times before but nobody had
recognized it and I gave Ron Perkins a
copy of it just out of respect for him
because it had worked with him for at
least eight years and as kind of a
humble if you will gave him a copy that
paper graduated veterinary school and he
sent me to Africa and this was an
indefinite period of time this is to
work on the white rhino conservation
project and African elephant
conservation projects and over the two
years I caught 200 white rhino brought
him back to the United States and you
see white rhino in a wild animal park or
zoo is one that I brought over our
offsprings are the ones that I've got
over and also cut another hundred and
took them up into what is now is in Bob
we and the the Central African country
of Zimbabwe and then of course so worked
on caught a hundred elephants and Cole
branded them and we tracked them and
found out where their places were where
they required water so they wouldn't be
taken over by livestock to save the
African elephant and two years into that
I was prepared to stay in Africa forever
because I was having such a good time
working on very nice projects and
Perkins sent me a letter said look I
just got this big grant from the
National Institutes of Health to study
pollution and they believe back in the
mid-60s the earth was going to end in
two weeks from pollution two said them
but we want to use the zoos as a canary
in the mind like the old Welsh coal
miners in England used to use Canaries
they take them down in the mind and if
dangerous gases would leak into the mine
as they were working the Canaries would
die and they knew they better get out
before they got killed by toxins or
smothering or something and so he said
we can use the big zoos in big cities
around North America Canada United
States and Mexico and we can find out
what the animals are dying from and
we'll learn how to protect humans and he
I need you back here for this and it was
based on that first mast off in America
from pollution paper that I had given
him so he came back I said I can always
go back to Africa this is a great
project came back and again McClellan
three short over a period of ten years I
did some twenty thousand autopsies 10
million chemistry's looking for
pollution 10 million flies to a special
saying looking promotion and what I
found was in 17,000 some change of over
454 species of animals and 3,000 human
autopsies I found that that every death
from natural causes was caused by
nutritional deficiency as opposed to
genetics or pollution and this is all
very well documented unimpeachable and
it resulted in 75 papers were published
in scientific journals went around the
world some of them went around the world
I was in the newspapers I mean every
newspaper the world several times and
then what it found out was that genetics
had nothing to do with any diseases
for instance they found type 2 diabetes
and crocodiles
I'm tempt you to be is supposed to be a
genetic disease in human beings how do
the crocodile get type 2 diabetes
of course you think well maybe he ate a
Baptist preacher who's doing missions in
Africa and then the the pastor had
diabetes and maybe got the chains in it
turned out I mean think of silly things
yeah I was just fit pattern right and so
what I found out was if there's a
nutritional deficiency in any vertebrate
whether it's a crocodile a turtle a fish
a human being a giraffe an elephant and
flamingo a rat a dog it doesn't matter
that same deficiency will cause the same
disease then finding sickle cell anemia
which is supposed to be a genetic
disease in the black community in
certain parts of Africa and it turns out
I'm finding it in hummingbirds and
antelope and deer and guy that published
I said oh gosh what's happening here
again it turns out that all these
different animals are vertebrates like a
human being ripped backbones and so the
same deficiency will result in the same
disease got all this documented need 75
scientific papers but the thing that
really hit home was a 1200 page
reference book that I wrote based on all
these autopsies 1,200 pages and all the
data from all the autopsies all the
chemistry's all the slides are in that
book and it's in the Smithsonian
Institute as a national treasure so I
was very very proud of that laughter
that project they moved on to different
zoos and I went to Brookfield Zoo and
Lincoln Park Zoo in Chicago in the Shedd
Aquarium and finding congestive heart
failure and dolphins and and so forth
turns out congestive heart failure
doesn't just happen it's certainly not
genetic it is in fact a deficiency of a
single vitamin we actually known that
one for 300 years discovered by a
Japanese naval surgeon and then
cardiomyopathy heart disease sudden
hearts as you see in young athletes we
lose about 10,000 young athletes on at
age of 20 here in America every year
from sudden heart deaths on the playing
field or in practice or at home after
they leave practice is caused by
deficiency of a single mineral I've
personally done 1,700 autopsies on kids
under the age of 10 that have died of
this disease
the heart disease and China's called
Keshawn disease and I went to the Yerkes
primate Center to pronounce turkeys and
it's a man's name and he invented the
primate research system in the United
States government and so this the
biggest one and the first one Lanta
Georgia was named after him the Yerkes
primate Center and it was attached to
the medical school at Emory University I
wound up there and I went there for six
months I found the first non-human case
of cystic fibrosis again I'm sure many
people had seen before but in their
training they were taught this is Eva
grossest was a genetic disease humans
and even if they would see something to
look casually like it they'd say well I
can't be it because of genetic in humans
well I've already done my 20,000
autopsies and 454 species of animals
3,000 humans and so and did all my
chemistry and so I knew better and I
began to look and sure enough I found
the cause prevention cure of cystic
fibrosis had found the ability to get
rid of the what they call genetic marker
which is found in 17 other diseases it
had no relationship to Barbosa so
if you get 17 other diseases that have
the same markers it's not a genetic
marker and what was interesting I got
permission to do biopsies of the
pancreas as delivers in the lungs of all
the other non-related baby monkeys in
the same colony at your primary center
same age group and sure enough they all
had cystic fibrosis that's because there
was something going on in the feeding
system there is opposed to genetics
tracked it down using my past experience
and sure enough I found it it turns out
the city grossest is a deficiency have a
single mineral the genetic marker is a
deficiency of a single nutrient and you
give all 90 essential nutrients 16
minerals 16 vitamins 12 Minister three
petty has it a little bit of extra that
one nutrient the genetic marker goes
away in two weeks and you give a little
bit more of the other nutrients that one
mineral and since you've roses goes away
I don't care if they're 25 years old
they've had it for 25 your doesn't
matter so slowly reversible no kid need
to be born with it no kid needs to die
from it and the beautiful thing here is
that I found also 200 these kids under
the age of 10 were
sudden infant death syndrome crib death
and so I know the crib death is caused
by deficiency at st. Merrill of the
cause of cirrhosis and kardama B heart
disease and it has not to do with
suffocating who they're sleeping on
their stomach which is a false theory
and then I found that 100% of these 1700
autopsies the kids had mustard history
making one is very sharp
figured out what was going on there
worked with the Amish community cuz they
have the highest rate of most registry
in the United States was able to begin
to reverse most registry in the Amish
communities still doing it today and
gave the information in 2011 to Jerry
Lewis and Jerry Lewis excitedly took the
cause prevention and cure of much
history to the most risky foundation
they fired Jerry Lewis in 2011 that's
why there has not been another telethon
since 2000 why are Jerry Lewis and they
should have their tax-exempt status
taken away most registry Foundation and
everybody who is in the board at that
time who bar Jerry Lewis should be put
in jail because every kid that dies a
muster disagrees since that point is on
their head yeah but this is something
that we see a lot of you talked about
your your cystic fibrosis I wanted you
to kind of get into that how you
discover that and what actually happened
to you and just going back I know from
your book bought it back a lot of
memories for me I remember as a kid you
working with Marlin Perkins I used to
watch a show all the time on Sundays
used to come on Sundays when I was a
child Wild Kingdom and but I was reading
your book I was freaking out because I'm
like oh my god it's got Marlin Perkins
this was one of my favorite shows that
and I remember right after that Disney
used to come on the the Disney movie of
the week on Sundays because I used to
stay with my grandma always watch those
and I just I was just freaking out when
I was reading the book listen I'm a dog
I know some Marlin Perkins but get into
your the Cystic Fibrosis because this
seems like it's a central theme and this
is actually going on today with a lot of
doctors who are coming forth with
different types of resolutions for
cancer and and different things but talk
about your experience what happened to
you about them with the cystic fibrosis
well when I found the city of roses I
knew there'd be some resistance to it
because it was in an animal not a human
so I sent sample slides to experts in
pathology and city of roses in three
different countries and all the big
universities and united states that had
experts in cystic fibrosis pathology and
they all in their letter had sent back
this is a classic cases hizzy broseph's
and then I shared with them that was
from an animal not a human they said
well is there any as a mother and father
still obviously yeah well let's get some
more babies and you know we can start a
colony of these babies have the genetics
they said well gets better than that if
you want a thousand baby monkeys or baby
rats or any animal you want to baby dogs
with physical doses I can make them Brea
in a couple of months because I know
what causes it's not genetics and I
compiled everything all my research all
the results from the biopsies of 24
other baby monkeys that had syphilis has
non-related
and took them to the powers that be at
Yerkes primate Center at Emory
University at the Medical School and
without a review without giving me a
chance to share the information all the
data they terminated me just the next
day I was given a termination letter
said get off the property immediately
follow a bluff and they didn't want to
be talking to anybody else is why you
treat me like a PhD student why don't
you get together a committee to
challenge my thesis here and get
together geneticist experts in physio
broses pathology experts and psittacosis
clinical care and pediatricians who work
with say grossest and challenge me and
my dad it doesn't satisfy them go ahead
and fire me but if my data satisfies and
let's get some grants and save some kids
and they fired me well that's when I
went back to school I chose to go with
the nature Pathak community which I knew
nothing about other than they liked
nutrition and I went up to Portland
Oregon then became a major panic
physician taught nutrition up there
taught chemistry for about two six years
Oh was going through the school and and
so forth and began to treat kids but I
would realize that people were getting
free treatment on city of roses it was
wrong treatment incorrect treatment it's
not going to save these kids lives
relieve symptoms for a while but didn't
really save their lives ultimately the
average lifespan back then was about 12
years old and today it's up into the 20s
because
of just vitamins and minerals and some
enzymes but if we were to be more
specific in what we do we could save
every kid to be perfectly 100 cent
normal or genetic markers go away and of
course this was in every newspaper in
the world when I discovered it and
Yerkes primary Center and Emory
University were making news releases the
National Institutes of Health making big
news releases how wonderful it was and
then when they fired me it was in every
newspaper the world again and they were
saying all this is fraudulent from blah
blah blah we were misled and and so
forth and so I again became a physician
I realized I was going to starve to
death and I was a winner where my wife
had died right at that same point they
fired me so he got fired and my wife
died I had four little kids year and a
half old eight years old to take care of
it and feed and so I had to deal with
arthritis and high with pressure and
heart disease and low thyroid and Alison
Rosie's and so forth and remember I had
done all these autopsies animals now I'm
finding every birth defect and
everything from llamas and monkeys and
parrots and flamingos and every kind of
mammal you can think of that were found
in humans and I just actually in many
cases discovered the cause just from
doing biochemistry and in many cases it
was reported in laboratory animals
what nutritional deficiency during
pregnancy would cause a disease and I
found how to prevent sickle cell anemia
how to prevent and reverse type 2
diabetes how to prevent reverse obesity
and the congestive heart soared
cardiomyopathy heart disease in Alison
Rosie's and people began to come to me
and so I was being able to survive by
treating patients for all the common
degenerative diseases well still my
priority was to treat as many kids with
physical doses and mustard history as
they could because we can save them and
bring them back into a normal society
and they will be perfectly normal and
even if you have two kids with cystic
roses a boy and a girl and a girl and
they fall in love with each other they
can have 25 kids and it will all be
normal no Natick every one of those 25
kids should have physical doses but if
the female takes all 90 essential
nutrients 16 minerals 16 vitamins Tomita
mazda3 been asses both the male and
female could have 50 roses if its
genetic every baby should from them
should be physical doses and I can show
you very clearly that that won't happen
same thing with most rotisserie
and so what I've been doing to nineteen
through nineteen seventy eight seven for
thirty-eight years
so what you're saying is nothing is
genetic and I think that that's coming
to the forefront now a lot of it has to
do with our eating I wanted you to go
back and just kind of pull out your your
veterinary experience there and a lot of
the meat and the dairy are big business
in our country and what I found in the
book was that they were able to kind of
limit nutritional deficiencies in these
animals in order to be able to bring
them to to slaughter to be able to get
the milk and things of that nature but
talk about how that's prevented in
animals and then kind of make that
correlation to what's actually going on
in humans and why while we're not
following this model in humans you are
but the the rest of the the medical
establishment really isn't doing that
okay well remember from those twenty
thousand autopsies those initial twenty
thousand autopsies I learned that any
nutritional efficiency is presented in
any vertebrate will give you the same
disease and for seasons almost all of
these are thought to be genetically
transmitted diseases either as birth
defects such as cleft palate heart
disease heart defects must receive
physical paralysis spina bifida Down
syndrome cerebral palsy these sorts of
things and the only thing that genetics
deals with is your gender your sex
you're either an xx female X Y male
you're you control your skin color your
eye color your hair color and after that
it does control whether your liver is
going to make liver cells as preparing
self your cartilage cells can make Carly
cells repairing itself but there's not a
single birth defect that's caused by a
bad gene there's not a single disease is
caused by a bad gene now you can get
radiation poisoning and mess up your
chromosomes but it's not something that
it's a natural degenerate disease caused
by a bad gene passed on from parents to
babies it's just not happening that was
an overreach because back again in the
1800's when they were discovering they
didn't
have the words gene they didn't have the
word dominance and recessive and hybrids
and and so forth and so but they knew
that a redheaded guy and a redheaded gal
if they had ten kids all ten kids would
have red here you had people with brown
hair male and female and ten babies a
nine could have round here one would
have red hair and they thought there was
hanky panky going on originally but
basically finally Darwin figured out
that there was something hidden in the
information transferred from mothers and
fathers and if they both have the hidden
information could pop up in one of the
multiples of babies and so this was the
beginning of the idea of genetics well
then medical doctors took it a bridge
too far if you will by saying all these
birth defects are caused by bad genes
there's never any signs to show that
Nana Linda Street if you feed a hundred
cows to have calves to make in the meat
and 70 of them have normal babies and
thirty of them have our babies of Down
syndrome and cleft palates and mustard
history farmers going to go out of
business the first year so we learned
that all these diseases are preventable
just by putting all 90 essential
nutrients that role alfalfa pellets they
can't sort of changes eat the corn
they're obligated to eat all 90
essential nutrients and this is because
there's no health insurance for animals
and so farmers whether it's milk are
eggs are meat or a bushel of wheat are
bushel of corn are bush-league carrots
it doesn't matter he gets paid by tons
and bushels by quarts and gallons and
dozens of eggs and and if he had to pay
for health insurance and everything
still comes out bad then a dozen eggs of
need 50 bucks a pound of hamburger B 50
bucks a loaf of bread be 25 dollars and
nobody buy it so I do by preventing and
curing diseases with nutrition in
animals we learn how to keep a dozen
eggs down to a buck 20 loaf of bread if
it's not gluten-free it'll be like a
buck 50 a quart of milk should be like
99 cents a gallon of milk should be 350
kind of thing instead of 15 bucks and so
we've been able to do that in the
analyst tree by preventing and curing
900 different diseases including birth
defects
plague people and I began doing this in
humans in 1978 38 years ago and I'm here
to tell you that every disease we've
been able to eliminate in animals is
eliminated in human and given beings and
I can make everybody's church family
type 2 diabetes free in two months or
less
I can make their City their County their
state America I can make the entire
world diabetes free type 2 W 3 in 2
months or less is very simple
nutritional deficiency and he changed
the diet you give it extra supplements
and it goes away
and of course right now in California 55
percent of adults in California are
either type 2 diabetics or pre-diabetic
55 percent and I can solve that in a
heartbeat but what happens is every
person you say this today say well I
better check with my doctor because he's
helping me keep my blood sugar under
control well managing your blood sugar
is like taking a aspirin for arthritis
you'll have pain relief but the
arthritis keeps getting worse because
pain is the symptom it's not the disease
high blood sugar is a symptom of
diabetes not the disease yeah come my
question is is I'm sitting here thinking
while you're tall made out but when
people start talking my mind goes to
different things so I want to ask you
this um I'm african-american you're
obviously Caucasian and then you may
have someone who's Hispanic you might
have someone who might be listening to
this who's Asian let's say that person
has a selenium deficiency are that is
that selenium deficiency going to be
different or kind of odd present itself
differently in me being african-american
versus someone might be who might be
Hispanic more versus someone who might
be Asian or is it all the same
hey ok if everybody's eating the same
diet the response will be the same but
the black community they tend eat a lot
of fried foods fried chicken fried fish
and fried potatoes and fried okra and
fried everything right fried eggs you go
to the Asian community they're eating
rice and baked sweet potatoes or boiled
sweet potatoes and so a slim deficiency
will react differently in those two
communities but ultimately if your
selenium deficiency is bad enough your
children will die a car
many heart attack errs handle yield a
Bacardi mopping heart attack and get
liver cirrhosis from the flame
deficiency you can get MS you can get OU
muster discrete fibromyalgia lupus all
these kind of things but it also is
going to depend on what you eat what you
don't eat as well as the deficiency and
this is where doctors get it all wrong
they say well yeah Wallach you know it's
been proven that you can you can prevent
mustard history and animals who has
never been proven in humans the less
were causing an animal research every
animal in that study is getting the same
diet we know exactly what's happening
you take a thousand people who's on a
study for mustard stream and humans
there's a thousand diet and it'll be
kind of subtly the same in the black
community totally the same the Asian
community so it subtly the same in white
community and so on and but the
deficient will be the same and all the
rates including all humans regardless of
their race but the diet will affect how
badly or how quickly or how early are
whether you're going to be resistant ok
people who are going to eat boiled foods
are going to have more tolerance for a
modest selenium deficiency as opposed to
somebody who is eating everything pride
if you're eating everything pride you're
going to die early and this is our
problem right now experts and then this
is published that our children will be
the first generation of Americans who do
not live as long as their parents and
this is a scorecard for the medical
system this is an F - - - - - - - ok
think about it our children are going to
be the first generation that did not
live as long as their parents everybody
who's listening your show today will be
standing your graveside burying their
kids if they do not if they do not
supplement their kids and watch what
they're feeding them I want you to think
I wonder what Steve Jobs his parents
felt like when they buried him I wonder
what I wanted parents as CEO and intend
those parents taught when they buried
him at age 55 I wonder what Vice
President Joe Biden felt like when he
buried his son Beau Biden at age 46
I wonder what s President Jimmy Carter
felt like when he bared his grandson
Jeremy at age 28 it doesn't matter how
politically connected you are doesn't
matter how rich you are doesn't matter
how fit you are as far as exercising if
you're deficient in these nutrients
you're going to die of a horrible
disease
and so this is our problem there's no
more nutrition or food is the closet
technology there's no more nutrients not
because of bad farming practices if
you're constantly switched from what is
a fuel to electricity that switch alone
has caused all of our nutritional
deficiency problems because people used
to put wood ashes in their gardens and
what actions are not minerals are Sydney
not answers what answers not ashes
they're minerals and so the plants would
take up these minerals you ate the
plants the pumpkins in the car and the
peas and potatoes and you got your
minerals that way people didn't know
they were getting enough but as soon as
they went to electricity
nobody had wood ash is put in their
gardens anymore no more minerals and the
accelerated downward spiral of American
health and the health of people in the
industrialized world the switch from
wood as a fuel to electricity is gone
gotten out of hand because doctors keep
saying don't supplement don't supplement
you'll waste your money we'll have
expensive urine as useless as eat well
and doctors get an F minus minus minus
minus because it is and it's on their
heads that our kids generations will die
before us it's just actually terrible
yeah you have a minor understand in was
it I can't remember exactly soil and I
know it's something with soil but yeah
so yeah how could a chemistry and yeah
so I wanted to ask you this how much of
our soil I mean you've been doing this
since 1978 was our soil adequate back
then because I've had people on who I've
talked about with the saw in their santa
soil is not advocate adequate enough to
add the nutrients to what we're growing
but i was wondering if you saw that way
back when since you were more privy to
that in that field that the Soraa was
being depleted well i began to see that
in 1958 it was i saw because that's what
getting my degree in agriculture my
major was animal husbandry and nutrition
my minor was in field crops and soils
which is again soil and crop chemistry
and i'm finding that when they put
fertilizer in the ground for crops and
large farms and ranches it's not for the
nutritional value of the food farmers
are not obligated to make nutritious
only valuable food for us they make
their living from tons and bushels so if
they can get the same amount of tons and
bushels from a fertilizer that has three
nutrients in it NPK two minerals well
human beings require 16 minerals the
food the parents only need three and
they knew to put the 90 essential
nutrients and the alcohol fat pellets
are giving you their animals the doctors
are saying oh no no no just eat while
you get everything you need
don't supplement and so the animals we
got rid of disease and the animals but
in humans we've got the diseases a
deficiency because the Sun was depleted
cause of bad farming practices because
we weren't putting wood ashes in there
twice a day to replete to rebuild the
mineral value of the soil
nobody knew that's what was happening
but that's what had happened for five
thousand years until he switched over to
electricity electricity has been were
the greatest boon to humanity but
another hand has been one of the
greatest negatives for Humanity because
we didn't know all of the unintended
consequences and most people don't yet
today that's why I spent most of my time
educating people on the fact that our
food has very little nutrition in it and
if you don't supplement it you will be
burying your children yeah I was going
to ask you that but you keep your
answering that over and over again that
we need the supplement because a lot of
people don't believe in supplementation
they say that we can get everything from
food but I just don't believe that
especially from hearing what I'm hearing
about what I'm hearing and constantly
interviewing people who's saying the
soil is depleted so I believe that you
should you should surrender your study
yeah there's a hundred-year said it just
ended by the US Department culture
started in 1914 and in 2014 what they
found out was that these minerals in our
saw were 500 times higher the minerals
in our cell were 500 times higher 100
years ago than they are today so think
about it grandpa got food that had 500
times more nutrients in it and his grand
babies and this was actually plotted out
in in 2014 united states farm
agriculture not me the united states bar
magnet culture came out and said 95% of
all americans are seriously merely
deficient because the result is totally
depleted
eighty
five percent depletion of Earth's oil
from minerals as it was in 1916 and
today it is five hundred percent less
mineral nutrients in it and our kids are
paying the price
our children are paying the price and is
one of those things where it's like Noah
everybody did not believe Noah even
though he preached for a hundred years
went around trying to get everybody to
understand what was going to happen here
and they better start building boats
that look like the art you don't get
their families on the boats and
everybody laughs at them and they all
died this is what's happening here right
now of course the average lifespan of
doctors is 56 according to their own
study which came out in 1999 the average
life span of medical doctors is 56 why
do people continue to believe them
that's because insurance pays for faulty
treatment just remember a couple of days
ago just a couple of days ago it's
published in the British Medical Journal
and as a study by Johns Hopkins the
reason why they had to go to the British
Medical Journal no American Journal
would publish it this is Johns Hopkins
Medical School from Baltimore Maryland
very famous and first medical school in
America they came out and said that
medical mistakes are the third leading
cause of death in America behind heart
disease and lung disease medical
mistakes are the third leading cause of
death in America Pharmacy any grants are
up there as well believe well well
that's another story when you look at
prescription decimal point errors and so
forth they're the number one cause of
death in America okay when you talk
about doctors advise prescriptions for
instance medical system actually caused
al-aziz now some diseases are not
genetic it doesn't it didn't just appear
people didn't have Alzheimers disease 45
years ago today is number four cause of
death and adults for the age of 65 it's
a physician cause disease that's a
deficiency of a small group of nutrients
and one of which is cholesterol who
demonize cholesterol doctors who came up
with a pharmaceutical group of the
standards of lower cholesterol
pharmaceutical industry and doctors and
by lowering your cholesterol they gave
America and the industrialized world
Alzheimer's disease
and they killed over a billion people
his 1952 in the industrialized world in
Europe and Asia South America and
Australia New Zealand the South Pacific
stuff United States Canada Mexico and
all the big cities all the places were
doctors writing prescriptions since 1952
medical doctors have killed a billion
people with Alzheimer's disease and as
various appearances and we know from
double-blind studies that we can
actually prevent and cure Al's and
Rosie's okay I've gotten rid of Alan
Center disease and many people diagnosed
by University diagnosed by big clinics
and just a few days on her program
they're back to work nothing wrong with
them after eight years of being
unconscious and being fed with g-tubes
and this is crazy and so medical doctors
have to be held accountable for this
medical doctors America have actually
killed more people than the Nazis did
this is one of the reasons that dr. King
dr. Martin Luther King jr. when he knew
that he'd won the civil rights movement
before he was murdered he was going on
to his next crusade which was to go
against the medical doctors because the
medical doctors America have killed more
and injured more and tortured more black
people then the Nazis killed and
tortured more Jewish people so he that
was his next project was to go after the
medical system before they killed yeah
there's a lot of stuff out there I
remember there's a book out there I
wanted to read in the future regarding
you know some of the experimentation
they did on black people I know one of
them they made a movie about the
Tuskegee Experiment so that that was out
there I believe that was on HBO Yale I
have it books one is black gene lies
which pastor Creflo Dollar for planet
charges yeah black gene lies he actually
paid for that book to be published it
documents all this and also the book
epigenetics documents the history of how
the medical system I mean painfully
grinding through maybe 50 pages of this
new book epigenetics all the terrible
things the American medical doctors have
done paid by the government paid by the
US government
all the experiments and all the terrible
things the Tuskegee Experiment was just
the tip of the iceberg it was there was
things were a thousand times worse than
the Tuskegee Experiment yeah there's
another book that I read a long time ago
because I don't want people to think
this is just segment on african-american
community there's a book out there and I
cannot find author I wanted to get her
on I think her name is Eileen Wallace
when I saw the plutonium files and that
goes into how they put plutonium in
people's oatmeal and it just wasn't
African Americans it was Caucasians it
was just about everybody so I mean
people aren't aware of this stuff but I
don't want to get into that of that
whole thing but I thought that you know
people should know that if you again if
you want to go and check the book out
and I have your book black gene lies I
want to actually get you to come back on
at some point and talk about that okay
but I'll and that's the spirit I want to
ask you about nitrates because there's a
lot going about on nitrous first of all
they were saying that nitrates were good
for nitrates weren't good for us and
then now I have some people who are on
the other side of the spectrum that I've
read some of this abstain nitrates are
good but there's a particular point in
your book you talk about nitrates with
lamb and I think what we need to
establish here on dr. Wallach is that
human beings are animals too I think we
tend to forget that but what were you
seeing in these lamb that were actually
consuming these these nitrates or
nitrites well again nitrates and
nitrites are a form of fertilizer and it
was also used as a preservative during
the days of the Civil War for ham and
bacon and those types of meats which
they could feed the troops on both sides
of the issue and when people died at age
45 it didn't make much difference
because it takes maybe 8 10 12 15 20
years for the effects of nitrates to
kick in and there's two things that
happened when you consume nitrates
number one it causes inflammation in the
body which is the bottom line cause of
obstructive arteries you get clogged
arteries and plaque in arteries it's not
cholesterol it's inflammation one of the
sources of information are the nitrates
you find in these preserved meats like
sausage and ham and bacon and Bologna
and salami and pepperoni jerky and that
kind of stuff and in 1971 when I'm
writing all my papers after all the
autopsy's 20,000 autopsies I'm finding
that nitrates and nitrates in human
beings were the cause of plugged
arteries not cholesterol in satrap and
so I'm flying in the face of everybody's
belief at that time and cilia today but
as also finding the cancer rate went up
in people who ate those kind of foods it
was published in a Danish
comparative pathology general actually
translated into eight languages went
around the world I was in every
newspaper of the world again on that
story how the nitrates and nitrates were
causing the plugged arteries and not
cholesterol and how the nitrates and
nitrates are causing cancer not genetics
and that was in 1971 and today just this
year the World Health Organization not
our CDC not our FDA not universities not
the American Medical Association not
state and national medical journals but
the World Health Organization came out
and said oh processed meats with
nitrates and nitrates in them and
nitrates and nitrites from any source
even if it's in celery is increases your
risk of any type of cancer as much as
smoking two packs of cigarettes a day so
that's what I said in 71 everybody left
him well your control house organization
now in 2016 saying the same thing that's
what my book is in the Smithsonian
Institute because I was saying in 71
well the interesting thing about this is
that if you are if you're smoking two
packs of cigarettes a day and you're
eating these processed meats of nitrates
M sausage and ham and bacon you're going
to get cancer and that's why our cancer
rate is so high in the industrialized
world compared to third world cultures
that don't have processed meats that
don't have preserved meats if they do
preserve means it's either by drying in
the sun dried meats are a salted meats
those are the only two preservatives
that these terrible cultures have and
they have 40 times 100 we do they have
104 252 population we have 104 10,000
now we have to do is give up the bad
stuff the fried foods the processed
meats the oils olive oil Cologne
everybody freaks out well everybody says
coke and hogs good for you well Hitler
said that you know taking a shower and
his deficit sillies was good for a2 and
so you got to understand what the heck
you're doing here
and just because they whoever they are
say it and it's on the cover of one of
these crazy magazines you find in the
grocery stores the tabloids does amazing
you know in the tabloids they said that
Altan disease is caused by alumina no
it's caused by doctors Al Jarreau
disease is a physician cause disease get
over it it's not a genetic disease and
it is not caused by aluminum is actually
caused by a deficiency of cholesterol
trace mineral deposit thankless doesn't
it yeah I mean I mean but it's all
connected I mean and I've been doing
this since 2005 and it's just like a
trail of you just gotta follow the trail
trace metal valleys here yeah
trace mineral depletion and we were
talking about minerals and the
deficiency of minerals and nutritional
deficiencies how does this trace mineral
depletion start is it from going to be
started from stresses is caused
primarily from our diet how does to
start and how do we start getting those
minerals back into our bodies okay well
there's several ways you can get mineral
depletion first of all it'll add e to
our which heat is not true your analogy
you are what you absorb there's a huge
difference between digestion and
absorption these difference between
putting something in your mouth and
getting into your bloodstream and one of
the biggest common causes of
malabsorption or your efficiency of
absorption goes down by 95 percent is
gluten intolerance this is not caused by
GMOs is not a new thing this goes back
5,000 years ago when the farmers in
Egypt switched from millet does the
grain because it had a half-inch seed
hit to wheat because it has a 3-inch
seed head so they tripled their yields
on their property the same property they
tripled their yield just by going from
millet which does not have gluten in it
to wheat which does have gluten in it
and so the Egyptian physicians were
recording all kinds of things they'd
never seen before
after they switched to we're talking
5000 years ago and so I take all that
information put it to work and so
absorption is one problem you can be
supplementing with all your trace
minerals but if you're not absorbing it
you're just making the septic tank happy
okay you're not getting it
so I took that stuff and I still got
time to be as well you got rosacea you
got big red ruddy cheeks you look like
you're you know an alcoholic Irishman
get on a gluten-free diet and then take
your supplements and your rosacea goes
away up your face it means you're
absorbing again Sam came with asthma
asthma I can get rid of asthma in two to
four weeks and anybody I don't care if
you've headed your whole life I don't
care if you're a three year old kid or a
three month old kid or a 35 year old
person had their whole life is a simple
deficiency of a single nutrient and it's
a very big clumsy nutrient and it's
difficult to absorb under ideal
circumstances and you get on a
gluten-free diet you take the 90
essential nutrients as what goes away
very quickly in a couple of weeks ten
days five days is very quick and nobody
should dive and no kid should be
miserable from it and nobody should
suffer from it because it's as simple
nutritional the business is aids then on
the other hand or food is totally
deficient of trace minerals because
plants do not need them plants only need
three minerals from the soil magnesium
phosphorus and C magnesium positon
potassium those are the minerals that
plants need everything else they get
from the air in fact we have too much
carbon dioxide in the air just grow more
food because they use plants use carbon
dioxide like we use oxygen so we don't
want to decrease the carbon oxygen in
the air by not producing it but what we
want to do is grow more food and use it
up so it won't cause any problem but you
have to supplement just like we did in
animals at the model you supplement we
eliminate all birth defects you
supplement we eliminate all degenerate
diseases you can't name me a degenerate
disease that we can't either reverse our
prevent in the woman's before she gets
pregnant and we can eliminate every
birth defect it's crazy we've done this
in animals over 100 years ago and we're
still diddling around with this in
humans because doctors are being
obstructive the pharmaceutical industry
is being obstructive because they make
their living with sick people they
really down deep heart don't want well
people because if everybody on earth is
well and taking care of themselves and
let's be 120 without him to go to a
nursing home doctor wouldn't be a single
doctor out there they'd all be modern
metal salesmen
I had a guest on here
couple of episodes ago we were talking
about iron and he said that we kind of
live in an iron dominated society and he
was expressing that iron is very
oxidative to our bodies in your book I
came across copper and it just so
happens that I'm 45 and I've been kind
of getting gray hair since I've been
yeah late 30s maybe and I was just
looking for a solution to the gray hair
and could I reverse you know the gray
hair everybody's trying to be young so I
came across copper and it seems like
from him and from what I saw in your
book is that maybe both of you have a
truth that I wear wear iron dominated
and we're not getting enough copper
explaining the role of copper as it
relates to animals and how it actually
relates to humans too and one of the
things I've noticed too is that with our
bodies we seem to want balance so we
can't have too much iron we can't have
too much copper it has to be that
balance if God can you talk a little bit
about that yes what is one of the things
we've learned in agriculture is that you
have to have all 90 essential nutrients
60 mineral 16 vitamins called meiosis 3
fatty acids and medical doctors and
people who become experts in a
particular nutrient whether it's iron or
vitamin C or whatever it might be they
tend to press on that well that causes
problems of its own nature
you need all sixty essential minerals
which includes copper and iron but then
there's 58 other minerals you have to
deal with they're all interactive and
anybody who takes a lot of something
without taking all 90 is putting
themselves in jeopardy okay and so this
is this is a seeker and animals you have
to take online you just can't take a lot
of one thing and think you're solving
your problem because the other 59 are
not in the food either and so this this
is the problem you have to think 90 90
90 90 not more iron and of course copper
and iron have a special relationship and
copper deficiency is very interesting
copper deficiency results in many many
and probably about I don't know 50
different diseases calcium deficiencies
147 different diseases iron deficiency
maybe 15 diseases iron is required
obviously for a
I was also required for myoglobin which
is a red pigment in muscle cells which
allow it to storm use oxygen iron is
also required as a cofactor in various
chemical reactions in ourselves our
bodies and so iron has a special place
and same with copper copper is also
required to make hemoglobin and copper
is also required for the health of your
liver coppers also required our nerve
transmission copper is also required to
make pigment pigments and so people who
are deficient in copper like Michael
Jackson was severely deficient copper
because he had a dietitian who is a
vegan and gave him nothing but grains
whole grains and vegetables and when he
was a little kid in the Jackson 5 he was
a very dark black kid but he got older
and older the tabloid magazine saying
his bleaching himself so he could look
white and by the time he was in his
early forties when he died from an
overdose of drugs he was snow-white I
mean he was whiter than a white person
he was white like a white sheet of
typing paper he had white hair the hair
he had was a wig you get a breakdown of
the elastic fibers your blood belt so
you get spider veins varicose veins and
hemorrhoids and hemorrhoids are just
varicose veins in a funny place you can
also get aneurysms ruptured aneurysms
and people die rub your hands all the
time and usually they will have white
hair regardless of age whether they're
six years old are there new barn and of
course there's a very good example of a
false genetic theory there's babies born
with aneurysms they'll die of a ruptured
aneurysm they're two three weeks old and
the doctor said well it's got to be a
genetic thing we'll call it Kawasaki
disease so some Japanese guy was the
first one to associate with genetics
well that's because the mother in early
pregnancy when the aorta was farming she
was deficient in copper and so the
embryo could make the cut of the plastic
fibers properly in the end they are
babies born with aneurysm and dies in a
couple of weeks and it's not a genetic
disease it's a simple deficiency of
copper early in pregnancy we eliminated
this in Turkey's one year every turkey
in America died of a ruptured aneurysm
and another year they died of all liver
cancer because you have all these weird
diets if they give
them and they have bad things in the
diets or they're deficient in copper and
so we learned that every turkey was
dying of ruptured aortic aneurysm
because their feet who is deficient in
copper we put copper at all stops so
back in the 1950s I began making sure
that not only animals of people got to
copper as part of their system then I
realized as more than just coppers more
than just iron more than just folic acid
is more than just calcium this is where
doctors get it wrong now they go from
one fetish to the next one year it's all
calcium calcium calcium peels the next
year oh now we got to talk about vitamin
D we're going to write prescriptions for
sixty thousand international units of
vitamin D when just two years earlier
they sent 400 international units with
Jim ups now they're they're giving you
prescriptions for vitamin D at 40,000
units and then of course they didn't
like probiotics you know to help balance
your intestinal flora well now they're
charging you forty five thousand dollars
to do a fecal transplant which means are
taking poop from their nurse and putting
the nurses poop in you and they get it
for free and they're charging a forty
five thousand dollars to give you an
enema somebody else's poop I mean how
crazy is this now do we need to actually
have a test for these these minerals to
see what we're deficient in or is it to
me it just seems like it's a question of
balance if you know that and obviously
everybody is efficient in these minerals
if we take something with I believe you
said ninety essential minerals in there
it's doubt that it is sixty now okay
you're on minerals yeah so if you take
something with these in there is their
needs is there a need to have any type
of testing done or should are you are
you safe as that your your safe car when
you're taking these 90 minerals and
sixes oh boy well here's here's two
things you have to appreciate number one
we have a system in our body that keeps
everything as normal as it can be in the
blood even if you have raging calcium
deficiency and on to your post you're
having fracture your bones your blood
calcium will oftentimes be normal
because your parathyroid glands are
pulling calcium out of your bones
contributing to the osteoporosis making
the
to try and keep your blood calcium
normal so blood levels of nutrients is
the worst possible thing to look at
because you have the system in your body
called homeostasis trying to keep
everything normal in your blood then
another good thing is a hair analysis
because if everything is below the
minimum data requirement and your hair
if everything is below that line that
means you're not absorbing because it
should you should have varying degrees
of different minerals if you're
depending on your food for these
minerals so we'll be in the middle some
will be low so it'll be below the line
and when they're all below the line that
means you're not absorbing and 85% of
Americans do have a gluten intolerant we
do have a CD called serial killers which
goes into a source of we find all the
places gluten is hidden and gravies and
soups and dog food and people allow any
dog oh yeah but you feed the dog you get
the dust on your hands then you prepare
your own food and maybe somebody else in
the household is throwing their laundry
in the same washer and dryer you are and
they're eating gluten outside the house
and bringing it in on their clothes is
that sensitive and so absorption is very
very important you are which you absorb
not what you eat but what we've done
taking all the 17 years of university
that I had and putting it into using
government statistics and government
information we know exactly what people
need in the optimal relationships and
ratios between all these nutrients we
did just slam them together there's over
a hundred billion dollars with the
research mine I've spent using other
people's money and like the government
and National Institutes of Health and so
forth a hundred well probably a hundred
million dollars but the amount of
research that's in the formulation of my
products is a hundred billion dollars
worth of research from all the big
universities the chemistry departments
agricultural departments of veterinary
departments the medical departments
chemistry departments all the research
by big companies also they're interested
in genetics and so forth and all that
research has gone into the ratios and
the ninetieth sensor new chancellor and
this product and so nobody else has if
you look at all the other multiples for
instance on the market they got 28
nutria
maybe seven minerals we're going to get
the other 53 they're not your food baby
farm look this is a scary thing baby
farmers only have three to five minerals
in we're going to get the other 55
minerals in a newborn baby he's not even
have a chance because he's not eating
solid food until he's maybe four to six
months old at least if a woman got maybe
20 minerals in her food she got 20
minerals or milk which is a lot more
than five and so what we've really put
ourselves in position everything we've
done technologically has been moving
towards killing our kids from
deficiencies you must supplement you
cannot just cherry pick one nutrient
supplement fancy I think I'm taking care
of my needs ah you got to take all 90
otherwise you're going to be burying
your kids yeah real quick I don't know I
got a few four five more minutes but I
wanted to get your take on a couple of
ailments I know a lot of people who have
high blood pressure and then there also
seems to be this exploding thing with
autoimmunity just everybody has
autoimmune diseases if you can tell I
don't have to go here in about three
minutes now so let me answer the
autoimmune thing you're right you have
more doctors are diagnosing more out of
you things fibromyalgia sarcoidosis
lupus rheumatoid arthritis next to the
genetic thing and the cholesterol thing
the autoimmune concept is the third
biggest lie in the medical system babies
are born bubble babies because Mama's
missing thing when their immune systems
are farming they're born without an
immune system because they didn't get it
made when they're in embryo when
somebody's 3540 years old they don't get
an autoimmune disease there is no such
thing it's actually a big lie but doctor
said you have an autoimmune disease that
he's saying that translates to I have no
earthly idea what you got I'm going to
blame it on your body attacking yourself
so I don't get responsible for it and
there's an insurance code for it so I
can get paid for it and then I'm going
to just treat your symptoms so you'll
keep coming in every month for the next
twenty five years if you live that long
and so anytime a doctor says you have an
autoimmune disease get on a gluten-free
diet take the 90 essential nutrients and
call me every two weeks and you will be
glad you got off your gluten got on the
90 cents of nutrients and you're autumn
you disease will go away I part eyes my
man I got to go yeah room I'm a guy for
the great work you're doing
dr. Wallach what is your website because
I know you have your nutrients the
nutrients okay they can get the
information they get the books they can
get the nutrients if some titled the
website is get B 90s at the numeral 99
zero get the th e 90 calm and the
toll-free number is 1-800-308-3515
number is 1-800-800-9797 iTunes and then
I did not put his information on the
show notes so I'll go back and do that
and just if you're out there listening
the website is get the 90 comm so GE t
th e 90 the number that is numbers nine
zero comm and then I believe you said
his number was one 808 three four six
one zero nine one eight hundred eight
three four six one zero nine so great
show today hope you got something out of
this show and Wednesday we'll be back at
our normal top time excuse me and we'll
have dr. Pam Riley on will be sparking
about essential oils a lot of things are
coming about about essential oils which
I've known for a long time about
essential oils and a lot of people are
discovering them more and more as one of
those things to be able to help with our
health help with our wellness help with
our longevity so Wednesday I'll see you
saying that time same bat-channel
peace and love y'all I'm out
why is it that when someone asks you to
just trust them
you just don't because Trust is tricky
you can't just say it you have to back
it up
triple-a auto insurance has been doing
that for over a hundred years as quickly
as a car accident happens Triple A
starts to set things right matching you
with the right experts who make your
claim their priority until you're back
behind the wheel talk to a triple-a
insurance agent at your local triple-a
store today or visit triplea.com slash
insurance to learn more about Triple A